ciccio
tu lo sai che c'è
io ti voglio un sacco bene quindi
prenditi il mio pene ciccio
ma che fai laggiù a milano io ti aspetto
[Musica]
e benvenuti a questo nuovo video io sono
per i gay sono con ciccio ciao ragazzi è
un grande esperto di geografia
soprattutto geografia siciliana dio
ragazzi sono il noto essendo nato in
sicilia a messina più precisamente lui
sa sa i posti quindi iniziamo subito con
una specie di joe kaeser siciliana
ragazzi party game
allora questa con ciclone in casa tua
non esca vacca che filmano dato quasi
entra nel sottosopra allora secondo me
quasi fa nelle zone un po più campagne
di campagna come questo te lo fa pensare
il fatto città che consideravo questo
ramo saravo qualcosa di vista va sempre
forse allora secondo me tipo posti come
se rinunci a selinunte e poi facciamo i
mezzi a in mezzo all'ultimo fulgatore
punto è arrivare qua tra busseto
palizzolo fu nel mediatore hai visto
come non era la era qua ss la sede in un
3 ma uno come bosco possibile farlo
impossibile però vabbè la c4 km
tagliavanti poteva essere molto peggio
ci ha messo molto di provini a casa mia
o guardali milano mi è stata fatta da
apple a madonna e io credo che quelli
che si rinuncerà noli la cosa
incredibile magistrati che siamo al
video che sono di qua in via grazia
soprattutto con paraguay ma che bel
posti a laser vecchio è un paesino
quindi è un paesino si va a sei vecchio
l'ultimo di tutti i paesi più vecchi è
anche le macchine non sono chiare la
panda del 2000 e mai
mammamia riprovava insieme vecchia nuovo
in questa partita bene ciano la cabina
ma internet call center o borgo giuliano
profondo giuliano credo che ne segue
padova 28 km ti stai sempre sentite
migliorando tanto era san salvatore di
fitalia tavolo andiamo avanti ma sempre
metropoli gomma 1 c'è libera qua c'è la
strada sterrata degli usa dettaglio
se non puoi passare ma fatemi dire
peraltro questo mezzo artici davvero
facile un albero è professore acquatico
le montagne ho letto la lettera la
vicino letta lo aspetta adesso resta da
tipo ha letto uno spettacolo nelle
giornate del parroco nelle alla se
questo è da questa parte che ne sai zero
euro del solito è un po come due sole
ecco che è di qua quindi volti regis di
qua il sole dovrebbe tramontare ad ovest
di solito la monta dovesse sorgere
quindi è che sta sorgendo tramontando e
che ne proprio così tramontando e che
cosa devo fà pensare lo percepisco
percepisci allora sta tramontando di
quindi questa e l'ovest e quindi qua può
essere se molto lontano però a porrazzo
mirò porrazzo ecco qua corazza era era e
l'arci era proprio vero se volete si
pagano immesso qua io all'inizio che
pure io vorrei roma bravo a quindi era
giusto una meta ci stava questo moro
cava che per l'attenzione di civiltà
civiltà vostro studio 100 si sarà
intorno
ciao ragazzi c'è qualcuno ad ora questa
la mappa di call of duty mese da quelle
piccole 22 ma io credo però 10 km sotto
a caso sono quello che arrivato più
vicino finora sigaro e leo a casa mia a
casa 12 stessi incredibile vicino al
villaggio faina madonna
guarda come cercato che diceva che le
incredibili
va bene basta sicilia basati la sicilia
fa mons places facciamo vedere che siamo
stupidi anni del web massimo poi spetta
se nei posti famosi nel mondo o che qua
ragazzi parliamo dell'udc un parka
urania in america blu certo che in
america
l'idea racconta sud america però beh
però la linea retta delle 9 a 7 mila
chilometri
in linea retta piena però vedere
chiaramente nella seconda risposta va
bene ok ma ci si può muovere ma proficua
e questo è il castello di hogwarts di la
aspetta guardato il manubrio
se adesso a sinistra il manubrio aspetta
guarda le targhe pigato francia ffs
quindi riguarda le aree o non è vero un
assolutamente grande palestra vice
andare avanti parco demonio ma ci ha
messo vicino vanta o che non è non è
comunque inghilterra a fare un giro a
pazzesco per arrivare da pazzesco come
si arriva dalla apple o o chiusi
titolare e faccio questo ho capito cos'è
secondo membro va in francia intanto
siamo veramente forti comunque va in
francia dal 15 tanti motivi ma non so
dove sia però secondo me o vendere quei
pilastri me no new york bis di un
santino di almeno era sanremo è vero e
santo c'era stato chi ha meno miley ci
mettete sempre chiese perché siamo
fermati a complimenti perché per questo
la qua bisogna guardarsi negli occhi
segni toilette orange mangia baghetti ma
scherzi
si è trattata di chiesa grossa
beh certo d'aiuto pratica sempre lì
vicino ciao cattive taglio inoltre dante
sharks bay certo ma la chiesa
semplicissimo per non c'è sempre una
pasta ma simile palle tribute onorati
dalla francia basta francia che cacchio
aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta un
placement fatta ma due foto abete lo so
io c'ho all'occhio per è il brand capito
il
bravi tutti i partiti pozzi che
conosciamo già cosa voglio salutarvi non
tanto questa chiarezza te lo da
qua proprio è tutto da questa parte
mentre un'altra cosa in francia per
favore francia a roma roma est a roma
grecia anche se non mi sembrano più il
territorio proviene solo qua dove che
era in turchia o ragazzi noi ma 500.000
basta francia vero basta francia avrò
quasi amore no eccolo gode gli ultimi
già trovato forma che francesco proprio
lui con 300 posti fino trovato una
bravissima come perché ho detto secondo
me san francisco è la mado ovviamente
magari fanno costrinse magri pall
la cosa che trovo bene ma cosa piazza
grazie alla foto piazza cosa sbaglia lo
sbaglia non ho queste mancanze non l'ho
mai visto ma come vorrebbero niente ma
dormo non è cliccato lei va dai e non
sia applicato qua ra qua bertola gioco e
ad ora gioco è sbagliato ripagherà in
garza nella prova sul sito segnalo
mandela ponte di messina dott
ecco che cosa alla ri ho capito niente
ma che tipo di mare sono storto che è un
gambero st masi 1 a domicilio se servizi
no no sarà cile cile santiago del cile
guarda qui corapi e bravo madonna per un
attimo ci ha avuto il panama da questa è
l'ultima ragazzi che si è facile questo
era chen siamo ovviamente successo non è
ovviamente l'autostrada sei grande
il suo creatore che non ho idea di dove
sei bianchini
no perché io eccolo qua bravo vai c'era
il pana questo è il parco il grand
canyon sta dove c'è il canyon che sarà
grand canyon medico è tutto qua quindi
teoricamente doveva solo parte del
canyon
di sicuro non so potrò mai essere più
vicino xi 133 km che per un per una roma
leggere e tantissimi infatti i fan ma
don professor ario cioè potreste
assumercela alla ditta di trovati dove
sia ma guarda vedo un albero era dire
qual è la sbronza nell iowa vediamo vedo
ragazzi spero che mi sia piaciuto se non
sapete dove siete chiamate ci siamo noi
che vi diciamo tutto dalla roma di stato
siti in francia però che vi sia piaciuto
iscritti a chiamare schiacciate il tasto
mi piace se video è cresciuto e noi come
sempre scegliamo bella ragazza aspetta
aspetta posso cambiarlo io certo
[Musica]